oh hi
there is no better feeling in the world
than holding on to an old grudge don't
you just
love that eternal flame that burns
inside of you forever just because
somebody once ate the last piece of
pizza the characters in this week's new
games are all about keeping those old
monkeys on their backs
kratos is still super angry at everyone
else in the entire greek pantheon
the zergs terence and protossis are
all still throwing down in outer space
and even people that you think would
typically get along like
vampires and frankensteins and sexy cat
ladies
are all still throwing down this week on
game life
it's all about old wounds running deep
the long-awaited first expansion pack to
starcraft 2
titled heart of the swarm is out on
tuesday march
12th in addition to making some tweaks
to the game's multiplayer mode
it also features a new single player
strategy campaign
based around the fan favorite character
sarah kerrigan
she's the terran who was turned into a
zerg hybrid but
spoiler was mostly changed back to human
at the end of starcraft 2
but she's still trying to lead the alien
zergs
even with her human body will they
accept her
if sarah's voice sounds familiar to you
that's because she's played by tricia
helfer from battlestar galactica but you
probably knew that already you huge nerd
you
our kratos is still
so angry
god of war ascension also available on
tuesday is the final playstation 3 entry
in the action game series
set in a somehow more violent version of
greek
myth the original god of war is one of
the most
astonishing games ever made but since
then the series has been more and more
just running on
fumes i played a few hours of this one
and it's really just the same old thing
what was once brilliant and surprising
and breathtaking
is now pretty much played out and
predictable it's still
fun it's a good game it's just
repetitive
other reviews from around the web by
people who've played the entire thing
pretty much confirmed my suspicions
although they do say the new multiplayer
mode is pretty good if that's the sort
of thing you're into
finally if you are right now fighting
the urge to buy a sega saturn on ebay so
you can play the classic dark stalkers
fighting games it's okay
stop close the ebay window and just
download
dark stalkers resurrection it's out
tuesday for ps3
and wednesday for xbox 360.
resurrection is a combination of the
second and third games in the series
which was basically a
street fighter style 2d fighting game by
capcom
starring a cast of horror movie
creatures
you know vampires and frankensteins and
sexy cat ladies like i said new features
for this version include high definition
graphical filters
and the ability to automatically upload
your replays
to youtube and those are your new video
games
and old grudges for this week we'll see
you next time